let me tell you why it's not the rich
man's fault it's so easy to always point
the finger to the rich man it's his
fault look at this rich guy
look at these rich people what they're
doing the rich keep getting richard's
all their fault some of you are not
gonna like this video
and i'm okay with that but if you like
this video put a thumbs up subscribe and
comment below
and share it with others let me get
right into it look you ever wonder what
we
learned about covid meaning so during
covid we gave away six and a half
trillion dollars of money that we
printed the government kept three and a
half of it for their own project
say they put out about three trillion
dollars of money to the people right
the three trillion dollars that went to
people who did it go to did it go to the
rich
no did it go to upper class no it went
to middle and low income families
however
even though that money went to middle
and low-income families
how is it that the money flowed to the
same rich people
how is it that the richest of the
richest got
richer more than ever before why is that
i'm going to give you a story about
myself here and it will go and you'll
see what direction i'm going with this
i am 21 years old okay
21 years old i've been running a
business i'm running on mte
i have no money left except for a
thousand dollar mbna credit card
so me being the genius that i am at 21
years old i have a strategy what do i do
i go to las vegas
and i call my friends uh freddie and all
these guys from valleys we're going to
vegas
as i'm turning everything around i
figured out this formula i watched the
rain man dustin hoffman i'm pretty good
in math i think i'm gonna
crack the code to blackjack so i go and
i'm a pretty good blackjack player but
i'm playing
aggressive because i'm trying to make up
fifty thousand dollars to pay off the
debt another fifty thousand dollars so i
can start a side business
look at the genius mindset this 21 year
old kid has who just left the military
wants to be mr olympia
but you know wants to kind of find a
faster way of making money
i go cash out five thousand dollars go
straight to the blackjack table
i play i'm gonna ask you a question how
long do you think it took me to lose
that five thousand dollars you think it
took me a day a weekend
three days what do you think it took me
maybe six hours
thirty minutes five thousand dollars now
you gotta realize five thousand dollars
may not mean anything today but five
thousand dollars
when you have a hundred dollars cash in
a bank and you're in that forty five
thousand dollars
all of your credit cards are maxed out
five thousand dollars like a
million dollars right it's a lot of
money to me 30 minutes
i go firsthand lose second hand lose
i went on like a 15 hand losing streak
it's never happened in my career before
but one by one by one by one by one this
thing goes i lose the money
in that moment i don't even know how to
describe to you how i feel in that
moment like
my friends are trying to be nice they're
like it's okay you know we met some
people we're going to go to the club
tonight pad because it's going to be all
right bro don't even worry about i'm
like don't even worry about it
i have nothing left to myself right okay
so i come back
and i'm broke i'm poor i was looking for
a shortcut
you know what happened during covet
here's what we learned during covet
there's three types of people that were
exposed both positively and negatively
during covet let me explain
the first were the poor that got poor
okay
the second were those who were broke
broke maybe on the outside but they
spent
years changing their mindset and their
habits
and the broke who became richer okay
what do i mean by that this is the new
money this is people that didn't have
money
they took certain strategies they put
their money in certain places
next thing you know pre-kovid they had
28 000
in a bank now they got 620. pre-covered
that 117 thousand dollars
in investments now they got a million
three pre-covered they were at 6
20 now they're at 93 million dollars yes
because they capitalize it
during that time and then you have who
the richest of the richest who just got
richer
the guy who was worth 50 million knights
were 280. the guy that was worth 380 now
he's worth 1.3 the guy that was worth 1
billion
now is worth 3.8 the guy that was worth
maybe 50 billion dollars who's now worth
a couple hundred billion dollars you
know what i'm talking about
what is the point no matter how much we
blame the rich
for getting richer we forget that if you
put money through the system
it's always going to flow to the same
exact people by the way
food for thought if i were to right now
we went through a system right now with
the government
and we give a million dollars to
everybody in america today unless you
say aoc's dream becomes a reality
let's give everybody a million dollars
hypothetically bernie sanders
what the hell do you think is going to
happen with that million dollars
here's what's going to happen a million
dollars million goes in
zero million flows to billionaires and
the rich and the job creators
every time the problem isn't who the
government's giving money to who the
government's bailing out or not
the problem is all these political
leaders who claim they care about the
people so much
when is the last time they got up on the
pedestal and said
go read these next 20 books
and change your mindset because this is
what this guy had to do at 21 years old
when he thought the shortcut
was to go put five thousand dollars on
blackjack and keep doubling his bet
maybe i'm gonna make fifty two hundred
thousand dollars and bail myself out
and that doesn't work everybody's
chasing the next short
you know cut to go out and make their
money just doesn't work so money's gonna
keep flowing to the right rich people
who keep creating value and keep
creating net for themselves
and unless you do the same as well it's
not gonna happen to you so if you're
watching this right now like i said
you may say pat i fully disagree with
you put a thumbs down i'm okay with that
but if you agree with this thumbs up
share this video and subscribe to the
channel and
if you're watching this i did a video i
don't even know how many years ago five
and a half years ago talk
the title is 11 skills millionaires
master if you've never watched this
video before
click over here to watch the video and
with that being said have a great week
everybody take care bye bye